hey it's evan and today i'm doing
another one of my fiverr gigs where i'm
reviewing a website of an entrepreneur
today i am looking at josh felber's
website and it's joshfelberg.com so
let's go check him out and see what he's
all about
all right so here it is josh feldberg
so i've seen the title says business
success
uh i look at this website
first of all i'm not sure who josh
felber is if it's this guy or this guy
maybe i should know who one of them is
by looking at this picture but uh i
don't
i think of this as some kind of
investment company this josh felber
venture
ventures llc looks like some kind of
investment company but uh
a
success coach okay there we go so
um this could be a little more clear at
the top
but overall a professional page looking
nice
typical format let's see what the next
one is innovative approach to leadership
this is an interesting choice of
pictures because i see one guy with a
barbell or a dumbbell or whatever um
but
this should be ideally more of a
leadership type picture if we're talking
about leadership
and serial entrepreneur great featured
on fox abc nbc cbs awesome that's great
so success coaching with josh is
dedicated to make your 10x possibilities
a reality jacques worked closely with
entrepreneurs from numerous industries
over the past 20 years
involved the complete proven support
system to help transform your business
and your quality of life
okay so is a success coach this is great
get get scheduled get schedule
what if you are ready to transform your
business in your life get scheduled
today for your okay so whatever you got
to fix up the grammar a little bit on
that but that's fine
um i like that you have uh an opt-in
here a way of capturing people who may
not be willing to
sign up for your services yet but you
have a way to capture them so they just
don't bounce from your website so my
business success strategy is weekly
core values this is great faith family
honor respect
a testimonial
michael savage
so i would love to see
okay so a couple things on this okay the
text is okay it's a little hard to read
space this out a little bit more add a
little more
sub-headlines to make it easier to read
okay let me know right away that you're
a success coach because i don't see that
here at the top until i get to this is
what tells me that you're a success
coach where it should be much higher up
and these pictures aren't telling me
as much as as it could right like you've
done a lot of great stuff this needs to
be highlighted
core values is great something i can
identify with this testimonial
it's too condensed
again you know highlight or bold key
areas i want to see a picture of michael
savage
or michael
savage hold on i'm confused is the guy's
name michael savage
michael savage platinum a master
religious coast at robbins research
international
michael savage okay so yeah i want to
see who's michael savage let's see a
picture of him here right have that
picture here instead of just you and
again this is way too long i'm not going
to read it so take out the best sentence
and make it bold and italics make it
easy for me to read the color scheme is
kind of hurting my eyes i don't know if
that is something that you've done on
purpose
but
you could switch that up to make it easy
for people to read and probably this is
a little anal but i sometimes get into
that on the website you know this is a
little longer cut that down to make it
easier so they're all the same size
next
welcome so we've got a video
13 second video let's watch this video
see what happens
come on youtube josh hubbard looks
forward every day to work to work with
coaching entrepreneurs to become
millionaires
okay youtube is messing up so we'll see
if that comes back we've got our
twitter account fifth biggest revenue
generating the movie frozen given disney
huge success okay
featured on oh videos coming back
it's a bunch of green lights and then
his logo
okay
well i clicked on it but it didn't
really do
much for me so if you're talking about
becoming millionaires
like that should be here right and show
me the people who you've helped and the
results they've gotten and
not just about athletics but becoming
millionaires
and then where else do i go
is that it it's just a one page site
oh maybe here
aha
okay this needs to be made way more
obviously people are gonna i skip this
over and i'm trying to do a review of
the website
this needs to be way more obvious at
least i mean this is okay from a design
point of view but maybe at least in the
footer having these things home about
josh coaching or did i just miss it no
it's not here
so i would definitely put those in let
me click on some of these social media
see what's happening so again josh
people come in your website and they're
missing this stuff so click have this
available lower down let's see about
josh let's see media oh we got a book
we got a blog let's check out a few of
the pages see what's up so let's check
out social media
so he's already on the new twitter
that's great he's got a lot of followers
awesome he's responding to people that's
great
he's posting frequently posting his
opinions this is all good stuff it's you
know you see it too often where people
create accounts on twitter they link to
it and then they never do anything with
us so this is awesome it's a great start
josh
google plus
same thing so he's got you know
followers some views he's uploading
stuff this is great
facebook same thing he's active
it's great he's got his his pictures up
here
i don't know what this award is for but
um it makes it look impressive so
it's a good start
looks like it's all pretty new here but
that's okay everybody starts somewhere
so good start josh
youtube subscribe to e.t the hip-hop
preacher i love e.t awesome we like some
of the same people
um so does he have videos i guess he had
that one intro
oh and some other ones so he got some
awards health and wellness
perfect
so let's go back about josh so this is
from clicking on here again man i would
change this logo up is just not doing it
for me i do not think success coach
coming from this
business success coach and fitness
expert josh filberg receives xp award
xp award for his appearance on tv so
first annual xp award i'm just thinking
like i have no idea what xp award is the
first annual xp awards was held at the
hard rock cafe times square experts
writers and
so i make this clear what the heck is an
xp award right up here xp award for what
make this super obvious okay it's great
i love the smiling picture looks
friendly approachable
love that
uh this page is crammed full of text man
i am not going to read all of this as
i'm really super interested in you but
you can keep the same content split it
up have sub headlines with bolded text
make it easy for me to read because you
have you've done a lot of stuff way more
than most people it's just not going to
come across because the website is too
difficult to consume what else josh
started crossfit training around 2003
believed that he was in great shape
running 60 miles a week working on a
daily basis
okay like even this i'm trying to find
points but it's hard to read this much
text so split that up i love to see a
video
you're an expert i saw a youtube
interview or something there i'd love to
see
a video and that could be on your home
page let's go back to the homepage
right here
message from josh hey i'm josh i'm a
success coach i want you to be a
millionaire here's my unique approach
and see why it's important to you
right talk about it that's that's going
to do way more than any of this stuff to
get people to sign up and you mentioned
that you have free weekly newsletter you
have a 20 minute free coaching session
with you that's going to get people on
board
so we've got this this is great like
this looks like a professional video
you've been on camera
you know you've won awards use that man
leverage that
book
coming september 2014 okay pretty cool
just make sure that it's up by september
2014 or you update this page because i
don't want to come here it looks bad
right if it's like october and it's
still not there
the website looks outdated but so far so
good i mean you could tease me a little
bit more you can have even a sign up to
let me know
i could sign up to know when it's coming
out send me an email what's the title
what's the topic tease me a little bit
but not not the other not the end of the
world and then your blog
so let's look at the blog so today is
what i'm filming this on may 14th it's
april 18th since the last post
oh wait
you have may 3rd down here may 8th so
how is this organized this is weird so
at the top of the blog is showing april
18th stuff but then may 8th
is that
so it's going to reverse order for some
reason may 8th may 5th may 3rd
uh
so
switch that around you want your most
recent one or at least a highlighted one
first but people are used to going in
chronological order
there's a lot of fancy technology on
this right like the the layout's nice
um
you know like even simple things like
this you hover over you get a plus with
this branded colors all that stuff has
been factored in it's it's that it could
be really beautiful there's some minor
things that with tweaking could really
make a big difference
so let's look at this one
recently selected to be part of the
mastermind x group
so you join the group again like this is
a brutal page to read man nobody's gonna
read all of this text crammed in
together at least you have a picture and
your pictures are great you're smiling
it's awesome
but uh you have to make these things
easier for people to read
the other thing is the blog seem to be
very self-centered which is like it's
good to um showcase
what you're good at and it makes me
think hey josh is an expert but
be a thought leader
right so showcase and obviously you are
you've had a lot of success so show me
through your blog your blog post should
be you sharing your opinions on stuff
otherwise this isn't a blog this is this
is your your press release pages if you
have a blog
show me
what you think is wrong with the world
and how you can fix it so if you're
talking about entrepreneurship and
becoming a millionaire what are some of
your secrets if you're a fitness expert
what are the things that i need to know
to become better at fitness right share
specific tips that will help me that's
what people expect in the blog otherwise
you're going to get no reaction right
like nobody's going to leave a comment
on this nobody's going to share nobody's
going to tweet it nothing because it's
just a promotional piece and it's hard
to read but a blog could be highly
successful strategy for you i you know
starting off i would pick one pick a pic
pick one strategy if it's videos or
blogs or twitter pick one and make it
awesome and then expand to the rest
so those are my quick thoughts on
joshfalbur.com
again make it easier to know that you're
a success coach
put a video in here make the pictures
related i'd switch up the logo
make make this easier to navigate
overall
make the text not so crunch together
make it easier to read with bullet
points and sub navs in there
and it's a good start man it's a good
start i'm excited to see your progress
and for those of you watching
let me know what you think let josh know
what you think leave a comment
underneath if you have more suggestions
for him i'm sure he'd love to see it too
leave it in the comments below
and uh for those who watching like the
video thumbs up below click on my face
in the top corner to subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you soon